Các con quan cò lý và giám nhẹ dưới gió thiết tại Cúc Sa Philippines, tôi qua ngày 3,5 năm,
hành hình khu trọng 2.5, chận động đất nông với tâm trên ngoài khơi đạo sẽ bui khiến
ý nhất 2.5 người thiết mạng và ý nhất 1,5 bụng mấy bình bị thương.
Lâm sự khoặc khu hãi nhất 2,5 tò nhà tại Cúc Bực Mình Chú Philippines,
các thị chân buồn, sân vì bí jô và mấy đe liên là những lươi chự án gưởng nặng lấy nhất,
bởi nhiều trường vật thương vong và cơ sử hạ tâm vì hư hông.
Bà đồ, chận động đất được xác định có độ lớn sau phê bẩy,
sau sau đó được trình lấy sau phê chiến, có độ xưa trên tiêu khoảng 5.5 người kiểu mẹ,
giúp trên được cảm nhận tại nhiều tình miền chung và một số khu vực miền 5 Philippines,
các quan để trên Philippines kẹn báo hả năng sẻ ra nhiều dưới chân mạng xó thảm hỏa này.
Kẹn báo xong tình bất thương đã được phát y như vậy bỏ sau đó bà dơ.
Cô hãi tình a ti, xưa bị tử vong xóa được bất sự kiện sẽ còn tâm.
Cơ không nên là cố gắng vẫn chuyển lên chiếm mẹ xuất để đen nhé nấu lực tình kiểu phát tốt,
tại vì cũng đã tạo bố bố lạng lên lúc tị sật lượng.
Sinh mua và các tình khác vẫn đang cho có chiếm cuộc hồi sau cơ báo,
tình có mẹ chung còn mẹ 2,5 tâm chiến đang hành hình khu chăm 3 miền 5.
Huyến đi nhất thảm yên bệnh người thiệt mạng, chủy yếu xa đuối nước và phía nước.
Cô ơi, kuyến điên bì ra làm chiến vình đa lượng thế bình dương,
cuối vực thư xác sẽ đập đất phản đối đường phút chào.
6. Một chịch đậu đất bày đậu ở vĩnh bắt đảo Lưu Zon,
khoảng đảo đồng dân nhất cả nưa đã khiến ý nếu nha rời thiệt mạng,
và hơn 1 chấp về biệt hợp.
5. Một chịch đậu đất sảo về một đậu của Lưu Zon đã quý hí sinh mạng của ý nhất mệ một hơi.